wiping our butts it's the simplest thing
in the world right we all do it we all
do it basically the same way or do today
we're going to talk with someone who
recently discovered that the way they do
it might be a little bit unusual and he
wants our help to figure out once and
for all
is it weird
[Music]
so all my life I've been standing up
right after using the toilet to wipe my
butt and I don't think that's weird I
think that's such a normal thing in fact
I didn't know there was another way to
do it but then people in the office
started telling me that it was weird to
stand up so today I want to find out is
it weird I began my investigation by
doing a thorough search online when that
was a dead end
I decided to pull 10 of Yvonne's
co-workers directly I absolutely think
it's the weirdest thing that people
stand up to white it's disgusting I
think I think it's weird I sit down when
I wipe my butt I am a very passionate
advocate for standing I feel fervently
about this I think it's extremely weird
if you're standing you're doing it the
wrong way I do think it's weird no I
don't think it's weird at all I think
it's totally [ __ ] weird standing up
to wipe your ass I think that's so weird
because the first off your butt closes
as you stand you can't clean it very
well like in a hot dog bun situation
you're touching too much bread you run
the risk of unspeakable consequences
what if you didn't realize there's still
some stuff there and then you stand up
and it's Falls not in the toilet leave
your ass on the toilet put your hand
between your legs and white as you sin
you're just you can just we can all
agree though no matter what your view is
whether you're a sitter or your stander
we all go around the back my best friend
goes through the middle and that's
[ __ ] you wipe backwards not towards
the front get it away from the genitals
you're out of your minds leave your ass
on the toilet put your hand between your
legs put your hand between your legs
[Music]
Yvonne's co-workers did seem to think it
was weird
but I needed a larger sample size so I
decided to hit the streets do you think
that standing up to why this weird no no
no could not be possibly than it is
thing that we do personally in the
bathroom do you think it's weird I would
say so I do think it's weird no not at
all no
I mean it's anyone's choice definitely
like fully stand-up that's really weird
no it's not weird yeah okay cool the
general public didn't seem to think it
was as weird as Yvonne's co-workers did
leaving me at an impasse
unsure of where to turn next I decided I
needed to consult an expert and this led
me to the office of a real-life butt
doctor yeah I'm dr. Maas godsey and I'm
here at the proctology and sit in
Beverly Hills you are unequivocally a
butt expert I am a butt expert is it
weird to stand to wipe your butt a lot
of people have a lot of different
bathroom habits some people stand some
people sit some people bend over to
clean themselves some people stand to
actually have bowel movements it's it's
it's very person to person independent
some people are super aggressive wipers
and they really tear up the skin and
they cause dermatitis and the skin
around the anal opening is super
different than the skin anywhere else I
can actually wipe my butthole too hard
yes you can I see a lot of that's
actually super common what matters is
are you having enough access to the area
needed to be able to effectively clean
the area a lot of people are very
passionate about their way and they
think that their way is the right way so
there really is no right way to clean
your butt if you're getting the job done
and you're not having problems continue
doing what you're doing I don't want to
tear up my butthole so I have a wipe
very gently pretend your anal opening is
like a very delicate wineglass be gentle
with it clean it very gently okay
so Yvonne I did some research and based
on what I found out I feel like I can
tell you conclusively it is not weird to
stand when you're wiping but it turns
out there is a variety of ways to do it
it's a whole rainbow of techniques and
there is no one way that's better than
the other it's whatever is comfortable
for you that's what I always thought
honestly I never judged anyone who did
it any other way
mostly because I didn't know there was
another way of doing it but I'm happy I
mean people should just mind their own
business and wipe their own butts mind
your own business and wipe your own butt
[Music]